now there's no stopping them everyone
wants to get home as fast as they can in
the side roads school buses stand ready
and waiting we climb into the one driven
by sway liebe arias the children called
her aunts Whaley she maneuvers the
minibus over bumpy roads through the
lower middle class suburbs east of San
Paolo sometimes she has to remind her
charges to stay in their seats
sweetly Barrios is self-employed her
second minibus with which she's in
constant radio contact could be
repossessed at any time she can't make
the payments anymore she doesn't show it
but she's in real trouble I took out a
financial deal for the minibus it cost
82,000 al and I used my private car as
downpayment I'm supposed to pay 60
installments of 2300 rayel per month at
all that makes 138 thousand so basically
I'm paying for almost two cars
on average Brazilian families Oh 45% of
their income to the banks
economist Georgina Guerra whom we met in
San Paolo is banking district says
that's dangerous
he says the lower middle class in
particular no longer has any purchasing
power in addition very few of them still
have a connection to money everything's
bought with credit cards that's why so
many have gotten into debts and the
bank's conditions are especially harsh
there's this old saying don't kill the
goose that lays the golden egg but
that's just what the Brazilian banks are
doing some credit card charges are so
high they border on profiteering if you
buy something with your credit card and
then pay in installments
after a year you'll have paid 10 times
the original value the high interest
rates enrich the financial system and
make the population or in the long term
when compared to other countries
including other emerging economies it's
clear that the margin between what the
banks pay in interest on savings and
what they charge for credit is extremely
high in Brazil those whom the bank's no
longer consider credit worthy are
targeted by posters like these in the
suburbs private money lenders looking to
get a cut of their own
we visits Whaley varios at home she
lives in a rented house it's small but
lacks for nothing in the kitchen she has
three daughters and the girls always
want something everything is bought on
credit she says that's the only way she
can manage there's no chuckles Aggie
PAGASA Colton I just can't pay the bills
on time then there's more and more
interest and then I really can't pay so
it's snowballs that's the truth at the
end of the month it's more than tight I
take a bit away here to plug a hole
there I try to get through somehow at
some point not even that worked anymore
swaye Lee Barrios sought help from
credit counselor Marcelo segredo he says
more and more small entrepreneurs get
into trouble it's a typical lower middle
class problem segredo blames the
government for the situation is he
growling TV domaine to pure overkill
Brazil either four is the amount of debt
is so great because Brazilians were
encouraged to spend more borrowing
limits were increased and it's become
much easier to get a loan but now more
than 60 percent of the population is
stuck in this cycle of debt that's
problematic for an economy that relies
greatly on consumption last year there
was little good news from the economy
now Guerra isn't the only one who thinks
Brazil has failed to take advantage of
many opportunities consumption and
agricultural exports alone can't change
the course he says Brazil is on a
difficult Road
a positive aspect is that Brazil has
really managed to reduce a great deal of
poverty but stronger instruments are
needed to provide more long-term
opportunities for social advancement and
educational training which are very
inadequate here in Brazil would be one
of those if that doesn't happen the
lower middle class will stay where it is
or even slide backwards Roger
sway Lee Barrios is afraid of moving
down the social ladder
she'd like to offer her children more
but there's no chance of a good
education because nobody here can afford
private schools first she has to solve
the financial problems she's having with
her vehicle
I see colorful things to cover the
minibus payments I have to take out a
new loan with slightly better conditions
that means more debt in the end I don't
see how I can ever escape this vicious
circle